bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuto questo
video sono parigi oggi saldo nati su
metro exodus che era da un po che non
portò video su metro è disponibile su pc
tramite l'epic store ed è uscito proprio
adesso il dlc di descrizione ragazzi
trovate il link per scaricare il gioco è
qua trovate la scritta che diceva il
link è in descrizione perché giampiero
ammontare molto bravo se la prendete
ragazzi ricordatevi di utilizzare il
codice krait alfa vj tv come sempre
perché è chi volete mente seno comunque
vediamo come questo di assisi che è
uscito bagno su capri joyce and storici
siamo privi blood evos privi ed bloody
vostro hoc
io russo sono sacco di vodka posso
uscendo su scendere non posso fare
niente fai fai tu sai tutto tu
buongiorno o si inizia a fare sul serio
come piace a me realtà ecco questo qua
pmr l'autobus che prendevo per andare a
scuola in realtà funziona così vicino a
torino
cioè fuori primo giorno la ma don tino
milano sabato sera rega allora fatemi
capire torca sbagliato ho tirato un
coltello sbagliatissimo e lui ha detto
wow
parco demonio ma che ho è che il mora
che spara orlando non li voglio fare
niente perché finché si sparano tra di
loro sono tranquillo però si gira solo
qua non va visto
certo non sono abituato raga con giochi
per rivedere i tasti perché avevo
giocato l'ultima volta con la tastiera
mannaia e quindi con gesti che deve
rivedere un po i tastini ma lo so tanto
non mi vedi se non ve tu non vedi tu non
vedi tu fai vai da uno pulisce dovevi
andare dall'oculista prego ma che
secondo me adesso salgo la scala è
quello ramifica un cazzotto in bocca e
lo so
amici di nessuno hai visto anno c'è un
altro bandito ancora e basta voglio
salvare sto qua che viene aggredito ei
sta tranquillo ti ho solo aiutato io lo
sapevo non sono in cerca di guai cerca
un imbarcazione che mi porti a casa
bene così una e si chiama titanic reato
bene di te la vostra va bene uno
schianto nel senso che ci schiantiamo
nel senso che è fatta bene perché
secondo me
a giudicare da come è messo tutto sto
posto non è che ci trovi qualcosa di
intatto ko ci siamo c'è un in faccia fa
niente pipistrello ovviamente
e morto giorno beh si carino
beh meno male che almeno non sono morto
cioè alla fine mi sono salvato per un
tour allucinante massa di pipistrelli
vabbè mi sa che stavolta devo sparare
madonna la mia collezione
togliti fai schifo
dov'è che stai andando esattamente zio
in tutto questo dovrei riuscire a farmi
scappare di qua porco demonio non posso
scendere posso fare scendere e salire e
scendere nel salire rimango qua
mannaggia la pupazza dove lo zio esci
del demonio è morto è morto
ce l'ho fatta a posto comunque tutto
questo mi capita non ho capito ma è
morto oppure è ancora lì che mi sta
dando una mano perché non vedo non sento
spalle o però devi morire ho capito e
vai giù madonna ai quasi minchia non
l'ho preso neanche un colpo aiuto
bravo madonna bravissimo proprio lui è
cascato un ponti faccia dai ho visto
mattinate peggiori soprattutto lunedì
capitano è morto in tutto questo periodo
per aggiungere il sottomarino lo
raggiungo per i fatti miei
se dicessi a trovare dei dei proiettili
in giro magari dovrebbe anche più facile
perché bello perché in qualche modo che
schifo porco demonio
togliti permesso nomi spuntano i popoli
prima e capitano dove dai avverato bravo
hai fatto bene
[Musica]
madonna lega sono kill bill
ovviamente mentre stai combattendo quale
la profetica nel più spontanea da dire
bye affanculo sergio calò minchia
ragazzi se solo avesse saputo creare per
a che fare con jackie chan cazzottone mi
ammazzo ti ammazzo tutti
questa è la faglia questa frase era
molto femminili soprattutto la parola a
tutti non si può dire nei video 3 non
riescono a fare niente bravo
sull'attentato di tesserarmi in questo
casino schiatta ma quanta gente c'è ma
basta a due ore
beh almeno non glielo resa facile ciao
mipiace questi stanno parlando
tranquillamente adesso dopo essersi
tirati cazzotti per due ore a fine ma ha
portato veramente col sottomarino
era questo che volevo arrivare qua
quindi a posto
signor gatto salve la ricordavo con la
barba come stai
piacere da ci siamo farmi piastra
barchetta ancora non ti preoccupare ti
investo poi con la barca quando torno
comunque robbie è bellissimo che ci
prendono a cazzotti 5.000 cinque minuti
dopo tutto a posto così dette forse la
vera pian piano sto tornando dov'ero
prima in partenza aspettarci qualcuno
lassù ci sono sempre bestiacce solito
tornando esattamente dove ero prima dove
mi hanno scazzottata uguale perché
esattamente lì prima stava al capitano
quindi se io dovessi cercare qualcuno
inizierei sicuramente dall'acqua
perfetto ho parcheggiato benissimo
meravigliose raga potrebbe essere qua e
potrebbe essere qua perché c'è gente ha
bisogno di munizioni assolutamente
munizioni all'attenzione tutto bene
basta fare vip colte cos'è la sveglia
mannaia allora salgo la scala
ok salgo la scala la scala e questa bene
start salvataggio ma come non posso
salvare o rapporti con le vacanze con
saladino scala adesso ho salvato molto
bene adesso se succede qualsiasi cosa ti
può saltare su una mina fare cose
bisogna guarda musiche mira brutta che
c'è il 0 davanti a te di fronte rughetti
avrei fatto a mancarmi attenzione
[Musica]
ma parco demonio conti sono cioè madonna
ragazzi è pieno di gente
devo andare se riesco al piano di sopra
perché sono vere piano di sopra e fatto
carroccio demonio riesco a destreggiarmi
la meglio secondo me poi non ha regalato
basta ho mai veramente difficile c'è
muoio subito non è vero cotto colpito
ragazzo si sente e non ho salvato otto
colpi e non ho salvato otto colpi e non
ho salvato la partita salvataggio rapina
non lo so ma ragazzi o finti colpi semi
ex vice gila rettili saprò mai se pro
ragazzi dovete morire
morite quanto tempo per mandar via anche
col corpo a corpo erano colpi li faccio
mi guardo in faccia sono colpi gli
schiaffi basta quanti siete
no ragazzi sono morto perché non posso
fare più niente di questo curare basta
molto meglio dove chi sta quel tipo non
riesco a capirlo dove bugo giù per il
culo esatto è esatto non capitano anche
ragazzi io non ho colpi no logo
non ho colpe oltre che colti però non è
anche i colpi l'hack è male porca
[ __ ]
apri la porta to testani culo non ho i
colpi io vi giuro che se muoio vi lascio
così senza un finale mannaia i primi non
ho corpi devo fare tutto colpo a korba
vi pare
mi sembra il caso almeno abbiate la
decenza di svenire sedi colpisco st
venimmo a quante mazzate dio d'arco tu
sei morto a posto posso salvare non
posso salvare guida che sono ancora in
combattimento e c'è un posto qua vivo e
basta madonna ne menava meno mia madre
coi quattro matematica
eccoti quello che ha detto lui va bene
non ho più niente gioco per forza fare
così io sono arrivato a posto sono
arrivato da lui a furia di mazzate sui
denti se non so se muori mario
buongiorno ho bisogno di te mi devi dare
una mano sul sottomarino devo andare a
casa in california perché è bella la
california fermo fermo offerta è di
tutti spetta ai ragazzi facciamo che non
vi spoiler oltre che se no mamma mi ha
visto facendo tutta la storia
questo era il dlc era l'inizio delle
leggi se volete continuarlo lo trovate
in descrizione ricordatevi di prenderlo
col codice creager parigi tv però mi sia
piaciuto molto figo ricordatevi di
salvare le munizioni perché le munizioni
sono importanti se non volete andare
avanti a gomitate cosa molto non me lo
sconsiglio poi fate voi volevo
ringraziare più games per la
sponsorizzazione e noi come sempre
signore e signori ci vediamo al prossimo
video ricordatevi meglio un'uccisione a
gomitata che non c'è point un'ora prima
churchill credo bella ragazza
[Musica]